mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
a version of this problem was an
interview question for admission to
oxford university
a prize is placed under one of five
objects
shilpa is privately told the shape of
the object and colin is privately told
the color of the object
shilpa and colin are mathematicians who
use perfect logical reasoning and the
initial setup is common knowledge
the host asks
do either of you know where the prize is
both of them are silent
the hosts then ask
do you know now
again they are both silent
finally the host asks do you know now
chopa and colin simultaneously say yes
the question is
where is the prize
i think the puzzle author professor joel
david hampkins and i saw this problem
via alex belos's puzzle column on the
guardian
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
shilpa was privately told the shape of
the object
if she was told triangle she would know
it's either the green triangle or the
blue triangle
if instead she was told circle
then she would have known it was the
yellow circle or the green circle
if she was told square then she would
have known it was the blue square
similarly colin was privately told the
color of the object
if he was told green he would know it's
either the green triangle or the green
circle if he was told blue he would know
it's either the blue square or the blue
triangle
if he was told yellow then he would have
known it was the yellow circle
so let's analyze the first question
the host asked do you know where the
prize is
both shilpa and colin are silent
so what does that mean for each person
let's analyze shilpa
if shilpa had been told square
she would have known the price is under
the blue square
she didn't know this she was silent
so we can eliminate that shilpa was
initially told square
now similarly if colin had been told the
color was yellow initially then he would
have known it's the yellow circle
but colin was silent so we can eliminate
this he was not told yellow initially
now shilpa has perfect logical reasoning
so she knows that since colin was silent
he was not told yellow initially
so shilpa can eliminate the yellow
circle as one of her options
similarly colin knows that shilpa was
not told square initially so he can then
eliminate the blue square from his
options
so now we go to the second stage of
reasoning
now the host asked do you know now
once again they are both silent
so we can repeat this type of logical
reasoning at this stage if shilpa had
been told circle initially
the only option would be the green
circle by this stage she would have
known where the prize was
she was again silent so this is not what
she was told initially
similarly if colin had been told blue
initially then by this stage he would be
able to figure out the prize is under
the blue triangle
but again he was silent so we could
eliminate this he was not told blue
initially
so we now go into the final stage of
reasoning the host asks do you know now
by this point shilpa realizes that colin
must have been told green initially and
colin realizes that shilpa must have
been told triangle initially
putting that together with their initial
information they both realize yes it
must be the green triangle
so they both exclaimed yes i know where
the prize is and it's under the green
triangle and that's the answer
what a fun logic puzzle
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you